vamos a observar este reloj y ver si
podemos decir que ahora está marcando lo
primero que vamos a observar es que los
relojes tienen dos manecillas y esto es
porque el tiempo en el reloj se está en
dos partes
primero tenemos las horas déjame notarlo
las horas
y las horas están representadas por esta
manecilla corta y por otra parte tenemos
los minutos así que también los voy a
notar los
y los minutos en un reloj analógico como
éste están representados por la
manecilla larga muy bien así que primero
veamos las horas y para ver las horas
vamos a fijarnos en la manecilla corta
que estoy señalando justo aquí se
observa esta manecilla corta está entre
seis y siete eso significa que estamos
después de las seis en punto pero
todavía no hemos llegado a las siete
porque las horas empiezan acá arriba y
van pasando alrededor de esta manera
hasta que pasamos por las seis en punto
pero todavía nos llegamos a las siete
así que son las seis y algo las seis con
álbum no sé tal vez sean las 6 15 o las
6 45 y no sé de hecho es justo lo que
vamos a averiguar a continuación pero lo
que ya sabemos es que estamos después de
las seis en punto
todavía no llegamos a las siete en punto
ahora para los minutos tenemos que
fijarnos en esta manecilla larga en esta
que estoy señalando justo ahora
en esta manecilla larga esta manecilla
larga se observa se apunta justo aquí en
esta marca y los minutos de nuevo
empiezan hasta arriba y van pasando
alrededor también de esta manera pero la
diferencia es que ahora cada una de
estas pequeñas marcas es un minuto así
que tenemos 1 2 3 4 y aquí tenemos 5
minutos cinco minutos observa que cuando
llegamos a este cuadro grande justo
donde está el 1 entonces hemos llegado a
5 minutos y después podemos seguirnos 6
7 8 9 y aquí en donde tenemos esta otra
marca grande llegamos a 10 minutos y tal
vez con esto ya estáis viendo un patrón
cada vez que llegamos a uno
estos números tenemos cinco minutos más
es decir cada vez que llegamos a una de
estas marcas gruesas o de estos cuadros
grandes tenemos cinco minutos más así
que seguimos hasta acá vamos a tener 15
minutos déjame ponerlo y si seguimos por
acá vamos a llegar a 20 minutos y si
seguimos por acá vamos a llegar a 25
minutos y ahora observa que no podemos
llegar al 6 porque nuestra manecilla de
los minutos está antes del 6 porque
llegar al 6 sería pasarnos así que
después de 25 minutos tendremos que
contar de minuto en minuto de uno en uno
para no pasarnos entonces tenemos 25
minutos 26 minutos 27
la manecilla de los minutos está en el
número 27 es decir esta manecilla ha
pasado por 27 de estas pequeñas marcas
hasta llegar a los 27 minutos o 27
minutos después de la hora entonces este
reloj está marcando las 6 con 27 minutos
muy bien ahora qué te parece si quitamos
este y vamos a trabajar uno más vamos a
hacer el siguiente reloj que tengo justo
aquí en este si nos fijamos en la
manecilla de las horas que es esto de
aquí puedes ver que está entre el 4 y el
5 entre el 4 y el 5 eso significa que
está después de las cuatro en punto pero
todavía no hemos llegado a las cinco
algunos minutos después de las cuatro en
punto así que las horas van a ser cuatro
muy bien ahora fijémonos en la manecilla
de dos minutos que es
que tengo aquí la manecilla larga que
representa los minutos empieza aquí y va
5 10 15 y no vamos a ir hasta 20 porque
la manecilla está antes del 20 así que a
partir de la marca de los 15 minutos
vamos a contar de 1 en 1 16 17 18 19
nuestra manecilla de dos minutos marca
justo aquí en 19 minutos así que tenemos
19 minutos después de las 4 o las 4 19
muy bien vamos a hacer uno más
ahora vamos a quitar este de aquí y
vamos a trabajar con este nuevo reloj
pero en este te pueden cargar que pases
el vídeo y vea si puedes averiguar por
tu cuenta que ahora marca este reloj
ok intentemos averiguarlo juntos y para
eso vamos a empezar con la manecilla
corta es decir con la manecilla de las
horas y si observas la manecilla de las
horas que es esta que tengo justo aquí
está entre el 7 y el 8 entonces es
después de las 7 pero todavía no
llegamos a las 8 y si vemos la manecilla
de las horas podemos ver que es bastante
después de las 7 en punto y de hecho la
manecilla de los minutos lo confirman
pero todavía no son las 8 ya que se
observa esta manecilla ya transcurrió
todo esto casi estamos muy cerca de
llegar hasta arriba pero todavía no son
las 8 así que tenemos las 7 horas con
cuántos minutos y la manecilla de los
minutos que es esta que estoy poniendo
justo aquí observa que para llegar aquí
empezamos acá arriba y fuimos
10 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 y un minuto más
un minuto más después de 45 es decir 46
minutos y entonces la hora serán 46
minutos después de las 7 o las 7 46 y ya
está